foreign
where do you stand on the question of
should we recognize that politicians and
leaders no longer really make much
difference to policy thank you manaveen
uh we've had two panelists talk about
the impact of democracy here in the UK
and but I want to cover it in a bit of
an international framework because I
want us to understand what democracy
means when you come from potentially you
know a third world country a country
that doesn't uh have a democratic
process or system my family came from
Afghanistan 24 years ago and I would
hope that you most of you would agree
that Afghanistan is one of the most
impoverished uh
anarchic sort of countries in the world
and 20 years of time effort money lives
were put in Afghanistan to build a
democratic system A system that people
sacrifice sacrifice their lives for
um I why my family came to the UK
because it's it's a country where
someone like me who came to the UK with
no understanding in the English language
um can now have an active role in
politics because my voice mattered
um me as a woman as someone from a
refugee background I originally thought
you know five years ago you know what
what I'm not from a white background I'm
not from a privileged background what
does politics or the political system
have anything to do with me and it was
actually our politicians and our
government uh and our British citizens
that convinced me that actually you do
matter and what you say in your view and
your life experiences matters and I
think sometimes we fail to understand
or even be grateful for what we have
here in the UK we need to cons of course
democracy is in trouble globally but
it's even more so why why we should be
looking to preserve it to look after it
and to make sure that citizens play a
huge role in how the country is governed
and how we introduce policies that
reflect the everyday uh lives of of the
population are you also work in the
civil service so I've also seen how
distant the Civil Service can be uh from
understanding the everyday struggles
that people face
um it is in some ways
over sort of overly bureaucratic uh very
slow
um and a lot of people who work in the
Civil Service have barely had any
contact with communities with
disadvantaged struggling communities all
across the UK and it's why some of the
policies aren't reflective uh or
understand the needs uh you know of what
we need to be the impact that we need to
be making so it's not perfect there are
many things that we should be doing uh
to preserve it to better to reform it
but the current system that we have in
the UK the political system the
democracy and the the institutions that
we've that we've developed here
um took hundreds of years and it's
something that I'm proud of and it's why
I'm proud to be British
I shot them
so stop starting with everybody's
pictures I think we get a sense that
clearly everyone on the panel in one way
or another agrees that politicians do
matter they are still shaping policy in
some respect but I wanted to move us on
to the question of is the idea that we
have a working democracy one that really
functions properly in the west actually
an illusion
um Aaron do you want to kick off on that
such a big question isn't it they all
are yeah like I said do we have a
functioning democracy I I think
I think in Britain I think it's somewhat
different to say the European Union my
view is and I'm sure there's some
disagreement here I think that we have
the worst of all worlds with our
political system we have a two-party
system like the us but without party
primaries and I think what that does it
means you foreclose new ideas new
individuals from addressing challenges
and problems and that's what happens you
know new challenges emerge over time
over the next hundred years we've got
the housing crisis we've got the climate
crisis we've got inequality and we
aren't producing capable politicians who
can address that because of real
shortcomings and how our two-party
system works in this country and it is a
problem and I personally think it will
it will actually get worse until we get
proportional representation I'm not a
lib you know I'm a Marxist I'm a
socialist I'm not meant to care about
little things like constitutional reform
but it seems really obvious to me that
we have a basic failure of solving
problems in this country when it comes
to our political class they're pundits I
think there's more and more I see
politicians or wet streeting or somebody
from the conservative party they go on
TV and they they have an opinion like
any of us they're a pundit that's not
what politicians are meant to do
politicians are meant to generate
answers and solutions to problems and at
the same time it's a difficult task to
represent their constituents in Civil
Society I don't think they're doing that
and I think many criticisms of
Westminster the bubble the elite in
London I think really it's not they're
culturally distinct to what we want as
politicians it's partly that but also by
virtue of that electoral system we're
always going to get the wrong people and
just just remind us how the primary
system would would change that yeah so I
think so the U.S has first passed the
post like in in this country so when you
vote in uh in an election you're voting
for a representative from a certain
constituency now what we have with
politicians in this country is you have
a constituency MP but they can have
effectively a job for life if they're in
a safe seat whereas in the United States
a senator can be primaried by another
registered Democrat or Republican and if
they're more favored then they then
become the candidate in the in the
election now labor ahead of 2019 labor
MPS were terrified about mandatory
selections is awful even though the
greens have it they've only got one MP
in their defense the lip Dems have it
and the SMP have it but this idea that
oh mandatory selection is so alien it's
so radical it's so left-wing they've got
it in the United States
and that to me spoke to the real
atrophied nature of of the debate in
this country about democracy and how
comfortable and cozy the politicians in
the media is in London and I think this
is a basic demand of saying we don't
want politicians for life in a
constituency for 30 35 years insulated
from people as long as they're on side
with the internal party hierarchy that's
not acceptable but that's precisely the
kinds of politicians we're producing
Calvin do you recognize those problems
so I don't disagree um I look at it from
a similar perspective I think the
problem is that we're taking on board
American politics I think we're looking
at our own politicians as if they're
presidential figures like did you vote
for Boris Johnson or did you avoid
voting for corbyn and actually we should
be voting for local Representatives
people who will represent us in the
houses of Parliament so we should
preferably be voting based on policies
rather than personalities but it is very
very personality driven at the moment
and that is why we're falling into some
of the traps that Aaron was just talking
about I think perform PR could
potentially help with that it could
narrow take us away from the two-party
system that doesn't really help people
on the ground and I know it's
controversial for conservative to say
that but it could could be a potential
win for the people
you know you brought a perspective of of
looking in at our democracy from abroad
um I mean do you think we should be
closer to the American system are there
things that you would want to fix
look I think
um as I mentioned earlier I'm not saying
that our democracy is perfect
um and I think potentially it may be
also that our conventional
interpretation of what uh a democratic
system means uh may also be slightly I
guess problematic or distorted
um I mean there are some radical
proposals there around how we have an
open democracy where public
participation plays a bigger role I
think France
um did uh there was a concept that was
uh had already started uh in France
where I think uh about 150 citizens were
tasks tasked with creating a policy
around climate change I think Canada had
also adopted adopted a similar approach
of um tasking about 100 uh Canadian
citizens to look at uh Tech uh big Tech
um and I think I mentioned slightly the
Civil Service and the fact that uh this
system is so disconnected in some ways
with the general public and it's why
potentially there are people who are
disillusioned with the political process
and with democracy that we need to bring
people bring the system to people rather
than the people to the system
um it needs to be a lot more closely
connected
um and and there are many ways where we
it can be reformed it can it can uh
include uh public participation and
encourage people to come forward with
ideas uh with new Solutions I think also
in some ways relying uh yes you know the
political process is such where we every
four years or so we vote for a candidate
or a political party and we expect them
to
to come up with ideas of how to solve
issues in local constituency or national
problems but there needs to be a way
where we're not simply relying on that
Member of Parliament or the the person
who holds office to come up with
Solutions but a way where people can
come to them uh with what they want
their community and their local area to
look like
um and that's where the problem is it's
that we expect politicians to come up
with Solutions whereas actually
politicians and the government should be
coming to communities uh and public
participation should play a bigger role
if I can comment on that yeah just just
because I I tend to disagree with that I
think to continue watching this video
click the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas